[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing harry
potter events and the medieval period do
you know the tale of godallo the dark
wizard or the history of early quinnich
how about the very first tri-wizard
tournament if you take a moment and look
back at the history of the medieval
wizarding world you'll find the answer
to all these questions
and more so join me as we track back a
few hundred years and learn a thing or
two about wizards and witches in the
middle ages
10th century dark wizard good low
continuing the tradition of herpo the
fowl godelo pushed the study of dark
magic to its limits
with the elder wand under his control
the dark wizard recorded his discoveries
in a book called magic most evil
through that book later wizards would
master many spells and curses that would
be outlawed by the ministry of magic
centuries later
interestingly godolo considered some
magical topics too taboo to write about
an uncommon trait for a dark wizard
although he knew a great deal about
horcruxes godello wouldn't explain how
to create them in his book his
contribution to magic aided lord
voldemort in the death eaters during the
20th century
he was also directly connected to harry
potter since he had once possessed the
elder wand the founding of hogwarts
about a decade before the turn of the
first millennium four powerful wizards
and witches gathered in scotland to open
the doors to a brand new school
these four figures godric gryffindor
salazar sutherland rowena ravenclaw and
helga hufflepuff would never have
believed that their school would remain
a thousand years later as one of the
greatest wizarding academies in the
world although the school created some
of the greatest wizards and witches in
history it was also responsible for
educating the most terrible dark wizards
like voldemort
11th century
quidditch predecessor early predecessors
of quidditch were captured in paintings
and books around europe and britain
one of these a game from germany known
as stikstock or stick stock bore a
striking resemblance
in it two teams of broom-mounted wizards
flew around a field
trying to score goals by puncturing a
dragon's bladder filled with air another
of these early predecessors came from
ireland this one called ingin gain
shares a few common traits but you can
clearly see how it diverges instead of
pitting two teams against each other
this game consisted of a simple racing
course which wizards individually raced
through
their time was recorded at the very end
of the course after they successfully
threw a ball through a goal with
circadogen versus the women of why
although the muggle world didn't know
about it there was another member of sir
arthur's knights of the round table his
name was circa dogan and he was a
one-caring member of the wizarding
community
during his time as a knight cadogan
faced off against a wyvern from river y
at first cadogan couldn't muster the
strength needed to defeat the beast and
was quickly beaten back
but in their second encounter godogan
struck a lucky blow and killed the
creature in a fiery display
bloody baron murders helen and ravenclaw
although he was one of the ghosts at
haunted hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry the bloody baron's deeds in
life should have prohibited him from
being around children
in the 11th century when rowena
ravenclaw's daughter helena ran away the
baron was sent after her when he caught
up with helena the baron tried to
convince her to come back together with
him
of course she refused and the baron
overwhelmed with anger decided the best
course of action was to kill the woman
he loved and that's exactly what he did
with the short knife the baron murdered
helena in cold blood
in the aftermath he was so overwhelmed
with the shame that the baron turned the
blade on himself
and took his own life
sword of gryffindor
sometime during the 11th century godric
gryffindor's famous ruby adorned sword
was crafted by the goblin named ragnarok
the first
the sword was so spectacular that the
goblins tried to steal it back from
godric but after a short conflict the
hogwarts co-founder quickly sent the
goblins home in defeat
chamber of secrets
during this century salazar sutherin and
his three other co-founders came to an
impasse southern refused to allow half
bloods and muggleborns to enroll at
hogwarts and the other three disagreed
in the end southern left the school but
not without leaving a gift he crafted
the chamber of secrets away from the
prying eyes of the other house leaders
and left it with a basilisk inside to
protect the honour of purebloods
malfoy's come to england
during the late 11th century the
malfoy's voyaged to england after
successfully aiding william the
conqueror during the battle of hastings
draco malfoy's ancestor at the time a
wizard known to his peers as arman
fought against harold godwinson
in doing so he won a nice plot of land
for himself as a reward and used his
status to rise through society as a pure
blood wizard
12th century
trading wizarding communities
throughout the 12th century the
wizarding community in britain continued
to evolve
during this time many new businesses
formed and bartering became a weekly or
daily event for everyday wizards and
witches
during this century the very first
glimmer of capitalism in the wizarding
community and the dent shopping district
of diagon alley can be seen puddle mayor
united founded wizards and witches
continued to refine the game of
quidditch and by the year 1163 the game
had become so popular that league teams
were established the oldest one puddle
mayor united was created this year
13th century golden snidget introduced
the golden snidget a predecessor the
golden snitch was first introduced in a
quidditch match in this century
instead of a small enchanted ball an
actual yellow bird named a snidget was
used and instead of awarding 150 points
to the winning team whoever caught the
bird was promised 150 galleons
by the end of the game every spectator
in the stands realized that snidgets
made the game much more thrilling from
that day on the birds were included in
every game
international warlocks convention in the
year 1289 a mysterious order of warlocks
convened in the secret meeting even if
you pour over the historical records for
days you won't be able to find much
about this clandestine conference since
warlocks were known to be
battle-hardened wizards it's likely that
the meeting was called in order to avoid
a new war in the wizarding community or
launch a secret one
triwizard tournament in the 13th century
the very first try was a tournament
between hogwarts bobator and durmstrang
was held
since that day the tournament has been
held every five years
for over seven centuries
although the games had been put on hold
in the late 18th century they eventually
returned during harry potter's time at
hogwarts in the late 1990s
a manticore attack during the medieval
era human settlements had forced many of
the magical worlds beasts and creatures
to the fringes
this meant dangerous encounters were at
an all-time low and growing ever rarer
but in the 13th century a savage
manticore attacked an innocent passerby
terrorizing the local community and
pushing the wizarding world to its
limits
in the end the manticore was too
powerful to capture
and ended up leaving the site of its
attack out of its own volition
14th century
golden snitch
during the 14th century the golden
snitch was finally introduced in the
game of quidditch this saved the lives
of thousands of golden snidgets the
yellow feathered bird which had been
used for centuries prior the creature
had nearly been put into extinction by
its use in the wizarding game
the golden snitch marked one of the
final changes to the game of quidditch
by the end of the century the only new
additions were rules declaring when and
where you could play the game
in order to avoid detection by muggles
more witch hunts throughout the 14th
century muggle persecution of witches
and wizards escalated with witch-hunts
and public burnings at all-time highs
the wizarding community desperately
pleaded in secret with muggle leaders to
stop the violence
with only a few royal families
interested in helping wizards the
magical community was forced to come up
with a solution themselves
so they created the flame freezing charm
which made the muggles fascination with
burning which is alive at the stake an
impossible feat to achieve
philosopher's stone invented
nikola flamel was born in 1326
and only a few decades later his
passionate pursuit of alchemy led him to
create the sorcerer's stone
with this stone he was able to produce
the elixir of life which kept him and
his wife alive for hundreds of years
at the time this was the only successful
creation of the stone which had been the
goal of alchemists for thousands of
years
more quidditch teams as the golden
snitch made the game of quidditch more
accessible more and more regional teams
sprouted up the wimborne wasps and many
more joined other established teams like
the pride of poultry and the kenmare
kestrels with so many swelling teams
sightings by muggles became more and
more common and so did the wizarding
court's fines for getting caught and
that's it for this video if you want to
know what happened in the centuries that
followed then please leave a comment
down below
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you